[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre los temas de esta semana
precisamente saludamos a Dominica
Vivanco ella es periodista de la posta
un medio digital ecuatoriano doménica
bienvenida Y qué tal termina usted la
semana
Muchas gracias a toda la audiencia y
todas las personas que nos ven una
semana en el mundo es un gusto para mí
estar con ustedes saludándolos desde la
mitad del mundo de la ciudad de Quito en
Ecuador yo te veo la semana bastante
cansada con muchísimas noticias
importantes acá en el país hay un caso
de corrupción que se que ha movido mucho
al gobierno ecuatoriano Entonces estamos
aquí con muchísimo trabajo muchísima
expectativa en torno a ese caso de
corrupción y también por un referendo
que va a haber en Ecuador la próxima
semana estaremos hablando de eso más
adelante domérica Gracias por estar con
nosotros saludo ahora a Fausto pretelín
Muñoz él es editor de la sección
internacional de el economista y también
es analista internacional Fausto
bienvenido qué tal termina la semana
qué tal Santiago gusto saludarles Pues
bien trepidante Mucha actividad la
coalición de los tanques allá en Europa
de los leopardos la coalición de los
leopardos interesante lo que está
sucediendo
y aquí en el estudio de France 24 nos
acompaña Ana María Ruiz productor
internacional y periodista de W radio
Colombia Ana María bienvenida un gusto
tenerla aquí en el programa Cómo terminó
usted su semana Muchas gracias Santiago
por la invitación muy bien una semana
Movida en términos internacionales
latinoamérica todo lo que fue la celac
una semana bastante interesante hubo
foco en América Latina en diferentes
puntos no Sí claro Bueno ya lo vamos a
estar analizando acompáñennos también
con sus opiniones y sus comentarios
también sus preguntas son bienvenidas a
través de las redes sociales nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es@antilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 todo junto todo pegado para
que dejen allí sus comentarios
comenzamos entonces hablando de Ucrania
hubo mucha presión a lo largo de esta
semana para por parte del presidente de
ese país bolodimir zelemski para que
Alemania se comprometiera a enviar
unidades de los tanques leopard otros
países sobre todo
europeos y también otros países de la
otan presionaron y esperaban una pronta
respuesta por parte de Alemania este
país dudó mucho no quiere fomentar una
escalada en el conflicto en Ucrania y
mucho menos despertar la ira de Rusia
finalmente los leopard serán enviados a
territorio ucraniano y otros países como
Polonia Francia el Reino Unido Estados
Unidos incluso Canadá también van a
enviar algunas unidades de tanques de
guerra que significa Esto entonces para
el conflicto ucraniano comienzo entonces
preguntándole a nuestra invitada en el
estudio Ana María comenzamos hablando de
Ucrania Qué significa Entonces esta
llegada de estos equipos militares esto
puede significar una escalada en el
conflicto que análisis puede hacer usted
pues es algo muy que se puede ver desde
dos desde dos aristas Porque si bien es
cierto que se habla de una Cruzada de
pronto más armamentística de parte de
Ucrania y de una intención de poder
escalar este conflicto recordemos que el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro se
pronunció diciendo que por el contrario
no iba a mandar armas a apoyar esta
guerra también es cierto que esto
implica un freno a Rusia pero también se
podría leer Incluso como una provocación
he visto diferentes analistas en el
mundo que si bien es cierto hablan que
esta inmersión de occidente más
directamente en la guerra es un aviso de
parte de Ucrania también dicen que como
puede ser una escalada también puede ser
un freno para frenar los ataques desde
el otro lado y así mismo Pues evitar una
escalada más grande de parte de Rusia y
de lo que viene siendo esta este ataque
constante Si se quiere decir de alguna
manera de parte de este país las
consecuencias las vamos a ver en las
próximas semanas y esto frenó a Rusia o
se simplemente fue tratar como abrir la
puerta para una escalada como usted lo
está mencionando Fausto su opinión Cómo
ve usted la llegada de estos tanques al
territorio ucraniano y hay una pregunta
que he tratado de de conversarla con
periodistas sobre esa duda que tuvo
Alemania por qué lo pensaron tanto en
Berlín antes de tomar esta decisión
cuando ya Berlín ha enviado armamento al
ejército ucraniano en el pasado
Bueno yo creo que Alemania tiene
elementos históricos que ata estas
decisiones y las hace reflexionar y me
refiero a las dos guerras mundiales creo
que Alemania Reflexiona mucho Sobre si
apoyaron no a Ucrania y cuánto apoyarlos
hay que recordar la premisa básica que
es la invasión la invasión de Rusia a un
territorio soberano como es Ucrania y
creo que estas decisiones esta coalición
de los de los tanques Me parece que
obedece más a un examen que hace
inclusive el presidente de Ucrania para
ver si hay cohesión alrededor de Europa
hay que recordar que 14 países europeos
tienen leopardo Más dos que quieren
entrar como es Suecia y Finlandia
Y de alguna forma es una respuesta en
contra de Putin que pensaba que a estas
alturas quizás iba a estar fisurada la
Unión Europea junto con el con Estados
Unidos Creo que este es una victoria
desde el punto de vista político más que
en el terreno es decir los los tanques
no van a cambiar mucho
significativamente inclusive hemos visto
armamento y ha entregado por Estados
Unidos Alemania antes que sí ha ayudado
Ucrania para recuperar alguno de los
terrenos y creo que a Ucrania debe estar
satisfecha y creo que debe estar
pensando que la estrategia le funcionó
porque ya ahora pasó a pedirle a los
países integrantes de la otan unidades
de aviones de combate f-16 que son
aviones que ellos no tienen en este
momento en su fuerza aérea Dominica en
usted cómo ve esta posible escalada
estamos ante un nuevo episodio esto es
un punto de quiebre en el conflicto en
Ucrania como lo decían a María un punto
que puede llevar a una escalada en el
conflicto o simplemente a empezar a
frenar la invasión de Rusia
yo ahí coincido como decía Ana María que
hay dos posibilidades primero que con el
cambio totalmente la estrategia
militarmente hablando el tener una
superioridad por en tierra con los
tanques como como pasaba antes la
Segunda Guerra Mundial no que se que
este era un elemento decisivo para poder
eh tener más más espacio en en tierra no
sin embargo yo creo que también hay otro
punto en Rusia la gente también ya está
cansada de la guerra es una guerra que
ha durado un año es una guerra que
también se puede leer más políticamente
que militarmente el giro de Alemania y
la unión de la otan es muy importante
más allá de los tanques porque
obviamente ahora ya se puede ver como
mucho más armado y mucho más posicionado
Ucrania pero también nos olvidamos que
en el que Rusia sigue siendo una
potencia nuclear militar Y que si al
Señor Putin se le ocurre obviamente se
puede hacer lo que él quiera o sea están
midiendo fuerzas pero yo creo que como
bien puede avanzar y podríamos tener
unos seis meses más de lo que hemos
vivido hasta ahora como puede ser que
digamos ya no más porque económicamente
tiene se beneficien de la situación son
las personas las empresas en realidad
detrás de todo el el armamento que que
mantiene peleando de lado a lado y que
no les lleva a ningún lado tanto a Rusia
como Ucrania Rusia ganaba espacio pero
Ucrania también ahorita tiene la
oportunidad de poder optar otro pase hay
que ver cómo se desarrolla todo eso y no
solamente los rusos están cansados
doménica también la Unión Europea
también los medios de comunicación
llevamos ya vamos a cumplir un año
cubriendo este esto que empezó como una
invasión que desde todos los puntos de
vista esperábamos que iba a ser una
invasión de unos cuantos días unas
cuantas semanas y estamos próximos a
solamente unos días de cumplir un año
del inicio de esta invasión Fausto
regreso con usted para hacer la ronda la
inversa seguimos seguimos analizando
esta coyuntura que hubo a lo largo de la
semana aquí entonces pudo más la
estrategia de guerra o la estrategia
política o la presión hablo en esta
presión que vivió Alemania para tomar
esta decisión que incluso hasta países
como Polonia le dijeron si usted no nos
da la licencia para enviar los tanques
lo hacemos nosotros sin importar que
usted nos dé la autorización
hay muchos países que están muy cerca de
Ucrania y que estaban presionando
Alemania como usted menciona Santiago
que es Polonia sin embargo insisto Creo
que este sí fue un un elemento o un
examen para ver qué tan Unidos están los
europeos y creo que han respondido es
decir si ha respondido Ucrania han
cerrado filas por Ucrania pero yo
insisto Santiago que desde noviembre
cuando el presidente biden autorizó la
entrega a Ucrania de escudos antimisiles
Patriot y también ha dado misiles
importantes
Eso sí han dañado mucho a los rusos
Entonces el tema del tanque Me parece
que sí más es un examen político que es
sobre el campo de la batalla Pero
insisto creo que para el presidente ruso
era importante que 11 meses después de
la guerra ver a los países de Europa
divididos y Estados Unidos divididos hoy
están digamos que cuestionados a veces
con con diferencias más a veces con
diferencias menos pero eso es una
victoria política para Ucrania Pero
sigue todos apoyando a Ucrania en este
conflicto Ana María aquí en el estudio
de France 24 no sé si en la redacción de
W radio que es el medio para el que
usted trabaja la intensidad del
cubrimiento en torno a la Guerra de
Ucrania ha venido un poco en descenso
cada vez se le da un poco menos de
espacio y esto vuelve y repunta todo
este debate que hubo en Europa por el
envío de estos tanques y Volvemos a
empezar digamos otro capítulo
informativo aquí porque estamos a la
expectativa a ver qué va a suceder y
cómo va a responder Rusia Se incrementa
otra vez la importancia de Ucrania en
los medios sí se ha incrementado pero
ciertamente yo creo que específicamente
en la W que es el medio donde yo trabajo
nunca se ha ido a qué me refiero con
esto antes teníamos una corresponsal que
de hecho también está aquí Catalina
García que estaba por momentos en
Ucrania digamos que en este momento
tenemos casi que fija una corresponsal
en Ucrania así como también tenemos una
corresponsal en Moscú que antes no
existían en la W entonces yo siento que
sí por momentos obviamente incrementa
pero a diferencia de otras situaciones
sociales que se presentan en el mundo
situaciones bélicas también por ejemplo
vemos el caso de la franja de gaza y
demás que están tan normalizados que no
se mencionan la Guerra de Ucrania es
algo que por la importancia política que
tiene Nunca ha dejado de mencionarse
puede que por momentos se incremente
pero yo desde mi punto de vista
Considero que no no se ha ido nunca
nunca ha estado fuera de los micrófonos
como que por el contrario siempre ha
estado en el ojo público y lo que pasa
es que en ocasiones incrementa esta esta
visibilidad pero yo siento que ha estado
permanentemente ahí por la importancia
política que representa no sé no sé
normalizó este conflicto como tal vez Y
lamentablemente y es culpa también de
los medios de comunicación se normalizó
por ejemplo la guerra en Siria de la
cual ya hablamos muy poco pero esa
guerra no ha terminado no ha terminado
y sigue habiendo combates y hechos para
reportar y la pero ahora Estamos
enfocados en Ucrania Fausto para ir
cerrando este tema para avanzar con con
los otros temas que tenemos en la en la
agenda qué podemos esperar de Rusia para
las próximas semanas siempre lo digo
también en mi programa del debate no
tenemos la bola de cristal para saber
qué va a pasar en el futuro pero pero y
bueno y menos con Rusia que están
impredecible pero pero qué puedo esperar
de Moscú
mire ha dicho a lo largo de los meses
que lo tan está en guerra y que lo tan
está participando en cierta manera si
hay una transferencia de equipo militar
hacia Ucrania por este tipo de
decisiones la entrega de tanques Espera
que continúe la guerra y logran o lo más
importante es en qué momento puede haber
o se puede asomar la diplomacia Esa es
la gran incógnita quienes tienen el
liderazgo para sentar a Putin y en una
mesa sobre todo de alguna manera en
momentos en donde Pues sí se va a
cumplir el año pero en particular
Quienes más han sufrido es la población
civil ucraniana que de alguna manera
pues lo sorprenden hemos visto en las
últimas horas todavía en los en los
túneles del metro gente refugiándose
Entonces qué se puede esperar que
continúe que se prolongue todavía más
esto porque es difícil ver a presidente
ruso doblar el brazo y la opinión de
doménica para cerrar este bloque de
Ucrania
sobre lo que puede seguir para los
próximos días
yo creo que
depender
mucho lo que pase
trial también como las las pérdidas
humanas es lo que puede generar una
presión también a los políticos rusos y
que podrían también generar otro tipo de
reacción dentro de la guerra ahora
también si es que hablamos de que si es
que Ucrania mantiene todo este apoyo por
parte de la otan también se está Armando
mucho más para poder continuar con la
guerra pero yo creo que el punto de
quiebre importante para poner o sea para
dar fin a la guerra podría ser A
mediados de este año a final de este año
no lo sabemos estaría dentro de la
decisión o sea estaría dentro del campo
de decisión de Rusia netamente netamente
así Cerramos el bloque de Ucrania y pues
muy atentos a lo que siga aconteciendo
allí en los próximos días sin duda
alguna Seguiremos reportando lo que
sucede en Ucrania en los próximos días
En donde también se mantiene la atención
es en Perú esta semana vimos más
protestas choques entre los ciudadanos y
las fuerzas de seguridad de ese país el
pedido es el mismo que la presidenta
Dina boluarte se retire de su cargo la
renuncia del Congreso un llamado a
elecciones y una asamblea constitucional
el gobierno mantiene su puerta abierta
para un posible diálogo entre las partes
también aceptó Investigar las muertes de
los manifestantes que perdieron la vida
durante las marchas sobre todo en el sur
del país en las últimas semanas la
crisis ahora trasciende las fronteras
porque el congreso peruano ya declaró
persona no grata al expresidente de
Bolivia Evo Morales y también ha habido
discrepancias con Honduras incluso
retiraron al embajador peruano destacado
allí en ese país
centroamericano comenzó También acá en
el estudio entonces con Ana María
preguntándole
qué dificultad
está presentando Perú en este momento no
es es claro la la crisis política pero
en cierta forma esta semana vimos por lo
menos a la presidenta Dina boluarte
tratando de llevar las riendas del país
que eso es lo que ha faltado a lo largo
de los últimos alguien que tome una
iniciativa y que lleve le de un rumbo al
país coincide usted en que de pronto
Perú pese a la crisis está empezando a
tener un rumbo para poder salir de esa
crisis como lo vio usted Ana María yo lo
siento muy complicado veo que hay
actores internacionales que de alguna
manera han hablado ya para que como
usted lo dice se tomen más las riendas
por ejemplo ayer en rueda de prensa del
embajador de Estados Unidos ante la oea
expresó abiertamente su apoyo a la
presidenta Dina boluarte sin embargo
también es cierto que si es real que ha
tomado las riendas también ha cometido
varios errores puntualmente quiero
referirme al caso de puno que es una
región fronteriza con Bolivia ya usted
lo mencionaba que Bolivia y Perú vienen
encontrados el expresidente Evo Morales
incluso ha terminado dentro de la
discusión pero es que específicamente
hablando de la región de puno una región
que tradicionalmente ha sentido incluso
más simpatía con Bolivia que con Perú y
que se ha mostrado muy lejos de Lima un
poco excluida de lo que son las
decisiones en el dentro del país Pues
esta semana se vio directamente excluida
por la por la presidenta porque dijo
abiertamente que puno no es Perú Aunque
es una región peruana sino que pues se
ha levantado en contra de Pues de todo
esto que ha de lo que ha sucedido ha
mostrado su su postura Pues por supuesto
en contra de la presidenta y también ha
mostrado un apoyo boliviano Bolivia
específicamente apoyado esta región
ahora la presidenta dice después pidió
disculpas pero pues ya lo había dicho
que puno no es Perú lo único que hace es
ahondar una crisis con una región del
país que históricamente ha estado
olvidada si bien es cierto que
ha tomado o ha intentado tomar las
riendas del país también es cierto que
falta unir a de pronto todas estas
regiones todos estos actores que han
estado un poco alejados históricamente
Ahora son tan trascendentales rompo la
ronda y paso a preguntarle a doménica
Entonces cómo ve usted el desempeño de
la presidenta boluarte se va a mantener
en el o la ve usted un poco tomando las
riendas de la situación tratando de dar
estabilidad
y yo la verdad es que no podría decir
que ella está tratando de buscar una
solución ella ha pedido que se adelante
en las elecciones claro eh lo más pronto
posible sin embargo también la represión
en las calles es bastante cuestionable
las protestas van por casi un mes hay 57
muertos según la última información que
yo pude revisar Entonces cuando tú
tienes las cosas bajo control yo creo
que se nota también las cosas lo que
pasa en la calle yo lo puedo comparar
con lo que nos pasó a nosotros acá en
junio del dos el gobierno perdió
totalmente el control de lo que estaba
pasando con los movimientos indígenas y
todo se descontroló en las calles la
policía hizo exactamente lo que está
pasando ahorita en Perú hay una
represión terrible a los ciudadanos que
están en su derecho obviamente de
protestar y demás pero la respuesta del
gobierno no es de no es conciliadora
ella ha dicho que lamenta mucho que al
tener que utilizar a las armadas a la
policía para poder reprimir la situación
pero sin embargo no da no plantea una
una solución o un el diálogo solamente
es por encima y no se habla ya de algo
real que pueda frenar los tantos días de
protestas en en Perú Fausto su opinión
de la situación en Perú los hechos de
esta semana complican la situación para
la presidenta boluarte
totalmente Me parece que el elemento
fundamental ahí en Perú es la ausencia
de confianza la confianza es el tejido
de la Democracia que cataliza
precisamente El ejercicio del día a día
de la política no hay una confianza en
el congreso no hay una confianza en la
presidenta no hay confianza una
confianza en el expresidente Y ese es un
grave riesgo porque genera una crisis de
inestabilidad política en ese país es
cierto la presidenta boluarte tendría
que renunciar por la mala forma en que
ha generado o ha administrado esta
crisis boluartes del mismo partido Pedro
Castillo está dividido el enemigo está
interno es está en casa es el mismo
partido político y enfrente está la
oposición con una keiko fujimori también
ya muy desgastada tres veces se presentó
en la presidencia tres veces la perdió y
creo que lo necesario ahora es repartir
cartas nuevas es decir que genere nuevas
expectativas y que los nuevos jugadores
traten de darle certidumbre a ese país
que ha caído en las últimas dos décadas
eh particularmente Por el vector
corrector de odebrecht me quedo con una
palabra Fausto que usted ha dicho
confianza me quedo también con una
palabra que he hecho Ana María y es la
unión unir justamente las regiones con
el poderío que tiene Lima a nivel
político en Perú ha sido muy difícil y
es uno de los grandes reclamos sociales
de los peruanos todo acontece en Lima y
las regiones del país tiene muchísimas
dificultades para tener un buen acceso a
educación a salud y todo se concentra en
la capital Cómo empezar a construir
unidad y confianza entre las partes de
Cara a salir para esa salir de esa de
esa crisis social política y en cierta
forma también económica que está
atravesando Perú rompo la ronda le
preguntó a doménica también pues es
prácticamente preguntarle cuál es la
solución al problema que creo que no es
tan fácil
Claro a mí me encantaría poder decir y
tener la fórmula para que puedas Cesar
toda la crisis en Perú que es una crisis
que eso no solamente vive en el en mi
país vecino sino también en varios
momentos de los países de latinoamérica
yo lo que podría decir es que claro
repitiendo debería Dina boluarte dejar
dejar el poder renunciar tratar de eso
sería el primer paso conciliador para lo
que está pasando en las calles que es lo
principal que están pidiendo a lo del
tema de la asamblea Constituyente no no
lo veo tan viable es algo que también se
está pidiendo sin embargo no es muy
claro yo creo que ahí lo que falta es
poder ponerlos los los puntos sobre las
diez y tener un diálogo real eh También
con los representantes de la sociedad O
sea yo lo diría que el primer paso para
la solución que se va a ir construyendo
durante el tiempo durante mientras ya se
cambia el gobierno es lo primero que hay
que hacer que se vaya a evaluarte no
coincidiendo entonces Fausto y Ana María
aquí en el estudio y en conexión remota
en que Dina boluarte debería dejar el
poder como Primer paso para
tratar de resolver la crisis Ana María
es complicado o no creo que sí pero pues
veamos Cuántos presidentes ha tenido
pero en los últimos tiempos la garantía
de nada y Fausto su opinión Bueno usted
ya nos había dicho que sí claramente Sí
definitivamente Tiene que dejar el poder
Claro que sí Bueno pues ya veremos
también dejamos tema abierto en torno a
la crisis de Perú seguramente vamos a
estar reportando lo que suceda en este
país a lo largo de esta semana porque
hay muchas cosas por resolver allí y
pues toca estar atentos por supuesto a
lo que vaya sucediendo allí vamos a
pasar la página en la agenda avanzamos
con otro de los temas que tenemos para
el programa de hoy Porque si hay un país
en donde la tensión está en aumento Esto
está como una olla a presión a punto de
estallar preocupa mucho en la región los
hechos recientes en Haití en el Caribe
hasta el momento ni el gobierno ni la
policía ni el ejército se han
pronunciado sobre los acontecimientos de
esta semana recordemos que la residencia
Primer Ministro Ariel Henry fue atacada
hubo daños materiales también dispararon
en las calles un grupo de manifestantes
se trasladó incluso alrededor de la
terminal del aeropuerto internacional de
Puerto Príncipe y retrasaron justamente
el aterrizaje del avión donde venía el
Primer Ministro procedente de Argentina
después de haber participado en la
Cumbre de la cepal Haití está inmerso en
un espiral de violencia un rápido avance
de las bandas delincuenciales allí ha
provocado todo este espiral y la ONU ya
pidió una fuerza de acción rápida
comienzo entonces con Fausto para hacer
la ronda diferente
Fausto Haití No da tregua una misión
extranjera entonces puede ser una
solución como empezar a a ayudar este
país caribeño que tiene tantos problemas
Sí yo creo que la primera es un
diagnóstico no es decir Haití ha sido
abandonado ha sido de alguna forma Pues
el país más pobre de de la región El
Caribe del continente americano
en muchas ocasiones la ONU ha pedido ese
tipo de intervenciones para rescatar a
este país y en el mismo número de
ocasiones no ha fructificado es decir
hemos visto como las instituciones en el
país haitiano se han ido pues cayendo
paulatinamente es un es un estado
fallido y como tal Y aquí vínculo un
poco lo de Perú se requiere generar
confianza y y ese es el gran el gran
objetivo en Haití es generar confianza
en las instituciones pero si la pobreza
está creciendo sobre todo después de la
pandemia que también hemos visto cómo ha
ido creciendo la la pobreza en ese país
pues difícilmente se va a restituir la
la confianza no Sí doménica su opinión
en torno al tema de Haití
ahí sí es un país que nosotros hemos
mapeado que está en problemas No es nada
nuevo problemas desde hace varios años
atrás
sumergido totalmente en la violencia y
yo ahí también tomando un poco la la
palabra la confianza es importante pero
también el poder resolver el tema de
violencia a la interna grupos criminales
cuando un país está dominado por esto es
imposible que pueda resolver sus
problemas estructurales y también los
problemas que pasan en la calle Eso es
lo que hemos visto ya de después de lo
que ha pasado en Puerto Príncipe las
protestas que están muy ligadas lo que
ya decía hace un rato en América Latina
en sí no es nada nuevo que existan este
tipo de cosas como hay en Perú y ahora
lo vemos también en Haití yo creo que
ahí también lo principal aparte de la
confianza es poder darle en realidad
mano dura a la violencia y al y a los
delincuentes organizados en este país la
la pregunta que me queda Ana María es en
qué a la comunidad internacional se le
fue del rumbo Haití Y esto quedó en
manos de las bandas delincuenciales de
los grupos del narcotraficantes de
Centroamérica de Suramérica y ya era un
país difícil de gobernar Pero en qué
momento la comunidad internacional se le
salió de las manos el país también de la
lupa yo siento que Haití ha estado en
realidad dos veces fuerte en la lupa
internacional una en el terremoto de
hace unos años todos recordando lo
terrible que fue y la segunda que fue el
magnicidio del Primer Ministro yo en el
Moisés pero más allá de eso y todos
conociendo el nivel de pobreza de Haití
y las dificultades que tiene Haití a
excepción de República Dominicana yo
creo que ningún país en serio le ha
puesto la lupa Haití vemos que de hecho
en este momento la mayoría de países
están sacando a sus funcionarios
públicos de allá no es por lo de ayer es
algo que viene de semanas atrás Entonces
es algo que que viene de siempre algo
que pasó ahora muy notorio en la celac
es que el Vice presidente del Salvador
que era la cabeza visible del Salvador
en la Cumbre dijo que a diferencia del
resto de países ellos iban a instalar
una
una comisión en Haití buscando
precisamente ayudarlos que ese es un
primer paso que no se ve y si bien es
cierto lo que se hace en El Salvador con
todas las maras y las bandas
delincuenciales el crimen organizado es
bastante también polémico incluso puede
ser cuestionable Es cierto que es un
primer paso que no los otros países no
dan yo creo que en realidad Haití nunca
se fue de de la de la vista
internacional porque nunca ha estado
solo ha estado dos veces ya se
sobreentiende que es un estado fallido y
se normalizó también la situación
en la introducción de la celac que no se
discutió este tema se habló de
democracia se habló de otros problemas
pero no se habló de Haití Fausto porque
América Latina no le Presta atención la
debida atención Haití
Bueno yo creo que es demasiada
ideologizado hay mucho dogma o Hubo
mucho dogma en esta reunión de la Celaya
en Buenos Aires
de alguna manera pues hemos visto como
si vemos como nació la celac es decir
como un ente que pudiera estar al frente
o cara a cara contra la oea hemos visto
cómo se ha ido deteriorando a lo largo
de los años y en este caso cuando se
invitan a tres dictaduras pues
lógicamente también hay fisuras de
credibilidad dentro de ese marco de o
ese mecanismo se habló mucho de
ultraderecha se habló y a bolsonaro qué
bueno que se hizo pero también hay que
ser autocrítica de lo que está pasando
internamente en la región
vamos a dejar el tema de Haití por temas
de tiempo debo avanzar con los otros
temas domínica le propongo que usted sea
la primera para opinar sobre el último
tema que tenemos para este programa es
la edición número 95 de la entrega de
los premios Oscar que tendrán lugar el
domingo 12 de marzo en el teatro dolby
en la ciudad de Los Ángeles en
California una gala que pues promete
renovar el interés que hay en torno a
estos premios debido a la caída en las
audiencias que han venido registrando
sus ediciones anteriores todo a la vez
en todas partes Ha logrado 11
candidaturas es la favorita de este año
pero también hay una buena
representación latinoamericana y que
decirlo la película argentina 1985 de
Santiago mitre está nominada en la
categoría de mejor película
internacional y es una categoría en la
que compite con muy buenas cintas
europeas también es una reñida
competencia la que va a ver ahí y la
actriz hispano cubana Ana de armas está
nominada por su papel estelar en blonde
una paradoja porque es una cubana
trigueña que se mete en la piel del mito
de la rubiedad y del americanismo en
todas sus formas qué les dicen ustedes
estas nominaciones algunos favoritos
cuales han visto Cuáles conocen Quiero
conocer todas sus opiniones Ana María
Ah perdón dominicana Sí perdón
no tranquilo a ver yo quiero comenzar
diciendo que no soy una experta en todo
el tema cinematográfico y yo solamente
les puedo dar mi mi visión un poco de lo
que he podido ver a mí me parece muy muy
chévere que se pueda y que tengamos esta
Apuesta por parte de Argentina en 1985
porque es también toda la representación
latinoamericana y como también estaba
citando Santiago Ana de armas en la
película yo creo que ahí sí todavía no
tengo mis favoritas para la mejor
película Ni tan todas las demás
categorías sin embargo creo que es una
una oportunidad muy importante para esta
gala poder reivindicar como ya decía lo
que eran los oscars en su momento yo
creo que después se tornaron demasiado
políticos hubo muchísimas críticas ahora
que estamos en el mundo de las redes
sociales por todos lados también fue un
escándalo la última gala de los Oscar yo
creo que ahora sí se deberían enfocar en
realmente poder premiar el el esfuerzo y
también la calidad de las películas yo
les digo no soy experta pero las últimas
premiaciones a mí me han dejado como que
con un mal sabor y y no tanto ha ganado
lo que se veía mejor o que funcionaba
mejor o que tenía un buen Entonces ese
es mi expectativa para este año Claro
que se está perdiendo un poco lo que era
la industria de Hollywood que era
entretenimiento era entretener a Más
allá de muchas reivindicaciones y usar
el cine como una herramienta política
pero pero era entretener Fausto su
opinión tiene algunas favoritas por ahí
ya había alguna de las nominadas conoce
algunas
Sí bueno la de la Argentina me pareció
excepcional la actuación de Ricardo
darín también Ana de armas interpretando
a a Marilyn Monroe me parece también muy
buena sin embargo esta película de blond
también está nominada para ser la peor
en otras en otro tipo de eventos
entonces bueno está entre lo mejor y lo
peor Pero Ricardo araní me parece
excepcional también un poco la excepción
de que yo esperaba un poco más de bardo
Es decir me parece una película muy
buena pero Pero quizás la traducción es
muy mexicana no es una película global
es una experiencia de González iñárritu
sobre su ira hacia su viaje hacia
Estados Unidos creo que la lectura en
México es más relevante que la la
lectura que se ha hecho en varias partes
del mundo y por eso fue castigada por no
ser nominada al mejor película y
Guillermo del Toro que también pareció
me parece interesante esta nominación
que tiene una película animada sobre
Pinocho
y por este lado en el estudio de France
24 Ana María bueno Yo como lo decía
dominical yo no soy tan no soy experta
en cine debo decir que Argentina 1985 Me
encantó Me parece que además es muy
importante reivindicar estos hechos
históricos el la típica frase Quién no
conoce su historia está dispuesto a
repetirla pues esta es una manera de
precisamente evitar eso y Y ya y también
como lo decía doménica Me parece muy
importante que se vuelva al rumbo de lo
que eran los Oscar porque Qué pasó en la
edición pasada lo que más tuvo
relevancia en los Oscar fue la cachetada
de Will Smith más por ejemplo que haya
ganado controversia
mejor película que además era una
película que trataba una realidad que
también civiliza mucho que es el de las
personas sordas entonces sí me parece
importante que siga por este este camino
de reivindicarse respecto a lo que fue
específicamente la edición anterior Más
allá de la política de todo eso la
polémica que al final lo que todos
terminamos hablando más de los ganadores
más incluso del mismo Oscar de Will
Smith que que pues no se tomó en
consideración fue la cachetada que que
le propinó a la otra persona y pues
ojalá que estos premios Oscar puedan
totalmente
yo sí quiero destacar la industria
cinematográfica Argentina siempre ha
logrado
meterse en estos grandes festivales es
tal vez la que saca la cara por la
región de América Latina junto con
México que también ha logrado buenos
espacios y buenas recepción a nivel
internacional pero Argentina hay que
reconocerle hacen muy buen cine es para
destacar Pero bueno es también una deuda
pendiente de la región de América Latina
fomentarle más a la industria
cinematográfica rápidamente para el
cierre muy puntual por favor porque me
queda un minuto Cuáles son los temas que
van a tener en la lupa para la próxima
semana doménica
Bueno yo les puedo hablar desde acá
desde Ecuador tenemos todavía el
seguimiento del Gran caso de corrupción
acá que está investigando la fiscalía
alrededor del gobierno de Guillermo
lasso Y eso creo que será lo que marcará
la agenda por acá a nivel internacional
yo creo que podríamos ver también el
avance de la guerra a ver qué pasará
también ya como Ucrania y Rusia la
próxima semana Fausto rápidamente sus
temas
bueno rápidamente es el tema de la
frontera en la migración es decir los
demócratas que que critican la propio
biden algunos de ellos por la la los
sobreexistencia del título 42 y en el
caso de México Pues el libro de de Mike
pompeo que pues prácticamente turista a
el canciller Marcelo embrazo bueno y me
están dando ustedes ideas para los
programas de la otra semana de Ana María
para el cierre yo creo que la crisis en
Perú es algo que va a seguir en el ojo
público sobre todo pues ver qué va a
pasar finalmente con la presidenta
Argentina boluarte creo que va a marcar
va a seguir marcando la agenda política
internacional Ana María doménica Fausto
un gusto tenerlos aquí en el programa
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros haber compartido sus
impresiones y su análisis en torno a los
temas destacados de la semana Gracias a
ustedes por la sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Luis
Fernando Montes y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
Gracias Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales
[Música]